[Musique]
je sais pas si vous avez suivi si vous
suivez l'actualité si vous intéresser à
ce qui se passe oui ils ont d'ailleurs
dit que le maroc on modère dès
maintenant et bien samsung va présenter
le 11 février prochain à san francisco
ces nouveaux smartphones alors on sait
qu'il y aura effectivement le successeur
antoine lé successeur du x10 brio ce
serait pas un nom est on arriverait
directement au s1 ça j'en ai déjà parlé
dans une précédente vidéo 2020 s'annonce
atone elle est tout aussi excitante avec
le lancement de pas moins de trois
nouveaux produits dans la gamme s
un changement de nom on sort du régime s
9 et suite elles disent on va pas sortir
le vaisseau on passe directement au res
20s 20s 20 plus on regarde le non plus
et s20 ultra comme ça on en voit là
vachement de ski vous l'avez pas déjà vu
j'ai invité à trouver je sais jamais si
c'est là aussi c'est là et a trouvé la
vidéo comme ça vous saurez tout sur ses
nouveaux smartphones vous saurez tout
sur les rumeurs tout ce qui va arriver
toutes les filles je vous dit tout
justement vous avez dit il ya quelques
mois si vous revenez un petit panda rien
vous deviez qu'effectivement samsung
allait sortir plusieurs smartphones
pliable en 2020 samsung devrait proposer
en 2020 pas un nouveau galaxy fold mais
carrément une gamme
c'est ce dont on va parler aujourd'hui
parce qu'il va y avoir plusieurs il y
aurait plusieurs smartphones pliable
alors ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui sur des
fuites
il est fils qui circule sur internet les
différents médias qui voulaient montrent
différents sites et on voit un petit peu
ce à quoi pourrait ressembler ces
smartphones alors déjà samsung avait
présenté lors de la conférence des
développeurs ont au deuxième semestre
2010 9 passes ils ont souvenez un espèce
de smartphones qui se plier en mode
philippe on n'était pas dans le galaxy
folle qu'on avait l'année dernière était
un bouquin qui s'ouvrait qui servait le
vrai écran se situe à l'intérieur c'est
celui là c'est du pays aux led cdu 7,3
poussent les roses en form factor
complètement différent un smartphone qui
se plie qui se replie un peu comme les
smartphones qu'on avait au début des
années 2000
pas si vous allez connu si vous
connaissez vous avez un grand smartphone
et là vous le replier comme un
smartphone à claques quelque chose du
plus petit plus compact mais plus
facilement dans la poche la technologie
du piètre non utilisé différemment non
pas pour augmenter mais pour réduire
pourquoi pas ça pourrait fonctionner en
tout cas sans réel sens mais c'est pas
tout parce qu'il y aurait également il
pourrait y avoir toujours si on suit un
petit peu ce qui se passe sur internet
un smartphone
l'ia bhl smartphones tablettes qui ne se
plient pas en deux mais qui se plie en 3
ça c'est marrant parce que lorsque
j'étais au csc il ya quelques jours à
las vegas j'ai vu sur le stand de tcl un
prototype de smartphone tablette pliable
qui se plierait en trois le smartphone
ne fonctionnait pas con c'était plus
simple trop tôt pour montrer ce qui
allait arriver il n'est pas forcément un
produit fini qui tournait mais en tout
cas on voit qu'à des marques qui
s'intéressent et qu'on pourrait y aller
dès 2020
[Musique]
et
m
mais
d
et
[Musique]
donc regarder comment ça ce pire est le
premier smartphone c'est le foll d'impôt
classique c'est ça c'est à dire que vous
avez un smartphone classique français un
grand smartphone ouvert oui je sais je
suis très fort en création pour les
médias directement en bas en commentaire
ça se passe comme ça ça se met comme ça
deux nouveaux smartphones je me suis
basé sur un smartphone stand a16 gaulle
de 6,5 pouces vos smartphones est grand
il est ouvert et vous venez nous
refermer comme ça alors j'ai pas pris le
conte fée qui demandent les dimensions
du châssis du contour donc ça serait en
fait un peu plus gros mais l'idée c'est
ça c'est qu'en fait vous avez un seul
même et grand écran comme ça que vous
venez replier que vous venez glisser
très facilement comme ça dans votre
poche ça c'est le point positif c'est
qu'effectivement on utilise un écran
pliable pas pour augmenter mais pour
réduire le poids un petit peu négatif
c'est qu'on va venir ajoute
effectivement de l'épaisseur de
l'épaisseur dans la poche mais sa passe
est très facilement dans une poche très
facilement dans un sac à main donc ce
format là il pourrait être vachement
bien alors ça c'est un petit peu plus
simple un peu moins compliqué expliqué
que le format qui se pliant 3 parce
qu'effectivement vous l'ouvrez vous avez
votre écran à l'intérieur vous à un
grand écran qui se plie on s'assure un
écran oled
maintenant il ya un point qui est
intéressant c'est au niveau des caméras
alors si on prend effectivement le
galaxy flip sais pas comment on peut
l'appeler eh bien là c'est tout de suite
beaucoup plus simple parce que vous avez
votre smartphone vous avez votre écran
qui se situe là que vous auriez
effectivement votre petite caméra qui se
situerait juste ici pour mieux prendre
en photo ça c'est plutôt simple une
caméra de 10 mégapixels
jusque-là ça roule lorsque vous referiez
votre smartphone comme ça vous n'auriez
pas si parfaite transparence
merci le marqueur et bien vous auriez
soit un petit écran de notification ici
au centre soit un petit écran de
notification votre côté comme semblent
le dire en tout cas l'ex digital
intéressant et vous pourriez avoir un
double module photo ici directement à
l'extérieur avec deux caméras de 12
mégapixels ça vous permettrait lorsque
vous ouvrez votre smartphone et bien
pouvoir photographier les gens
directement avec votre caméra comme ça
en le prenant en main sans que ce soit
problématique sans que ça vienne gêner
et lorsque vous l'ouvrez et que vous
voulez effectivement prendre des photos
bien vous avez votre caméra de celle
fille ici on s'attend pas forcément ici
avoir les meilleures caméras on n'aura
pas une caméra de 5 mégapixels nous on
aura quelque chose qui sera vraiment le
taf
et tout ça pour être est ce qu'ils
savent vraiment pas déconner tout ça
tomberait sur un sens dragonne 855 pour
essayer de gratter un petit peu en
termes de coût ce serait un écran de 7
pouces de diagonale bien
évidemment amoled je pense qu'en terme
de caméras on aurait une caméra
ouverture variable vous savez la caméra
qui ouvre à f 2.4 f 1.5 pour capter le
plus de luminosité possible ça c'est une
techno de samsung qui est prouvé qu'ils
marchent donc pourquoi pas l'intégrer
directement là dessus une batterie qui
seraient entre 3000 à 3500 millions
terreur on irait jusqu'à 256 gigaoctets
de stockage
parlons maintenant du nom pour le non
j'imagine pas que ça me saoule va
l'appeler le galaxy folle 2 tout
simplement parce que déjà un galaxy fold
alors en fait quand vous mettez un
numéro 2 quand vous changez la
numérotation derrière ça veut dire que
vous restez dans la même typologie de
produits dans la même idée de produit
mais que vous venez juste un petit peu
rafraîchi rapporter des informations
faire évoluer la gamme là pour que ce
serait pas une évolution du galaxy folle
ça serait un nouveau facteur donc serait
forcément un autre nom il ya différentes
rumeurs qui circulent sur net le galaxy
flip ne sais pas comment est ce qu'ils
vont appeler peut-être c'est dans l'idée
du f
fall dble flip pourquoi pas ça pour
avoir un sens bon je sais pas toujours
été que ce smartphone qu'on pourrait
trouver aux alentours des glaces en
dollars moins cher que le réseau de
motorola qui luisent autour des 1500
dollars donc un smartphone qui serait
vraiment destiné à toucher beaucoup plus
de monde que le galaxy folle faire
rentrer la technologie du pliable donc
beaucoup de foyers
[ __ ] très des foyers très clairement et un
smartphone vous pourrez retrouver sur le
marché aux alentours d'avril mais 2020
dans cette idée d' alors bien évidemment
je vais partir à san francisco avec
samsung j'ai la chance de partir avec
samsung à san francisco comme ça je vous
dirai tout vous parlerez de la longe
montrer réellement ce qu'il en est si on
peut les voir vous saurez tout en temps
et en heure avec les tweets les images
les facebook et instagram l'accompagné
donc vous invite à vous abonner ici sur
youtube et à me rejoindre sur instagram
monsieur underscore sur twitter monsieur
gros et surtout les réseaux facebook et
compagnie ne me rejoint comme ça on en
parlera ensemble en ayant notre sens
facteur qui pourrait être intéressant
c'est l'idée d'un smartphone qu'ils se
plieraient en trois ans qui se déplie
ray en trois lits d c'est que vous
auriez un smartphone comme ça vous
pourriez l'ouvrir ensuite on l'utilisé
avec un petit écran vous l'ouvrier ça
vous ferait un smartphone un peu plus
grand et la louve rayon grand vous
aurait carrément une tablette sasp lit
dans tous les sens puis pas que dans un
sens ça peut sembler fonctionné je vous
le dis j'ai vu un proto un peu dans
cette idée sur le stand de tessé au c
est pas du tout fonctionnel donc pour
l'instant c'était vraiment espère
démontrer monde avance sur le pliage
l'on vous montrera ce qui arrivera très
très très très prochainement mais moi je
prends cette idée assez intéressante
pourquoi parce que si vous réfléchissez
par rapport à ce qu'a fait samsung sur
le galaxy
tout simplement eh bien vous avez un
smartphone avec un tout écran
notification vous l'ouvrier et vous avez
votre smartphone comme ça là vous pouvez
l'utiliser avec un plus grand écran ça
faisait smartphone pliable mais lorsque
vous leur fermier dia vous avez petit
écran notification là l'idée c'est que
vous auriez un écran de smartphone un
vrai smartphone vous l'ouvrirez comme ça
vous aurez effectivement bien un petit
peu je dirais le même format qu'un
galaxy folle voire légèrement plus
réduit et lorsque vous ai vraiment
profité au maximum
eh bien vous ouvrez tous en grand ça
vous fait une tablette donc en fait vous
avez un smartphone avec un écran
probablement 6,5 6,7 pouces que vous
allez ouvrir en grand s'est offert une
énorme tablettes toujours plus compacts
toujours plus réduit mais partout
lorsque vous les payez vous avez plein
d'autres usages saas est vachement cool
lorsque vous l'avez comme ça vous avez
un écran ici qui dit un écran va
demander forcément une caméra lorsque
vous l'ouvrez en deux et bien cet écran
qui hélas rien disparaître il faudrait
donc ici une caméra ne serait ce que
pour travail collaboratif
quand je vais pas le faire la même
bêtise qu'ici j'ai refermé le marqueur
indélébile et je vais prendre un stylo
ne sera beaucoup plus simple
donc on recommence ici les noms votre
smartphone il vous faut donc ici une
petite caméra soit une soin de soi des
bulles d'un côté de l'autre lorsque vous
l'ouvrez comme ça il vous faut également
une caméra lorsque vous allez dire
travailler sur du budo compagnie et si
et ça quand vous avez les plus gros
millier pouvait pas venir avoir deux
petits points sont ici vous allez donc
d'avoir déporté sur une bulle d'un côté
ou de l'autre
donc on peut imaginer une bulle avec
pourquoi pas un double module photo ici
qui me permettrait d'avoir une caméra
principale est un ultra grand-angle ça
pourrait fonctionner mais lorsque vous
ouvrez la complète et vous retrouvez
avec ces espèces du trois caméras celle
là celle là est celle là et là ça
devient relativement bizarre du coup
celle là on peut dire qu'elle a pas plus
sa place ici mais qu'elle a davantage sa
place ici sur le côté avoir une bulle
mais là vous aurez quand même un écran
avec trois caméras
c'est pour ça que ce format me paraît
quand même relativement bizarre qu'ils
peuvent pratiquer mais il est bizarre
mais lorsque vous l'ouvrez comme ça vous
avez besoin aussi de caméra à l'arrière
pour venir faire des photos alors il
faut imaginer que si vous le replier
comme ça eh bien vous avez cette partie
là qui est caché donc le module photo
aurait plus sa place là lorsque vous
replier comme ça c'est toujours cet
espace lac est disponible donc pour le
module photo arrière voyez très
clairement il ya une seule possibilité
qui se situe ici ou là vous auriez je
pense un triple module photo sa part
être en tout cas avoir un sens grand
angle ultra grand angle au téléobjectif
et pourquoi pas une petite caméra
contré sur un produit quand même très
haut de gamme donc en termes de photos
c'est quand même bizarre voyait les
usages que je trouve cool parce que vous
preniez votre smartphone
hop je navigue ok pourquoi pas ça me
fait un smartphone classique au keops
aph
je veut l'ouvrir je suis sur un fol ça
dépend des formats des vidéos et là je
veux travailler en mode tablette qui
vient beaucoup plus grands alors on
pourrait se dire ok pourquoi l'ouvrir en
intermédiaire alors prononcé en plus
grands directement f qu'il faudrait pas
un autre système
est ce que l'idée loubert camp mais ce
n'est pas juste une excuse pour venir
l'ouvrir comme ça il n'y a pas une
question qui se pose sur les usages sur
l'intégration des caméras sur
l'intégration des composants en tout cas
son principe ça m'aide à beaucoup de
réflexion et je savoure vraiment
intéressante à vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
pour un peu négatif quand est ce que
vraiment voir arriver là dessus et bien
c'est l'épaisseur parce que là je vous
montre sur un bout de papier donc c'est
très très faim si vous l'imaginez fini
construit si effectivement ce produit
arrive pour l'instant c'est pas du tout
sûr en tout cas c'est une idée une piste
vu ce qui circule sur internet
eh bien vous aurez comme un produit qui
pourrait en tout cas être
potentiellement relativement épais et
qui dans une poche ou toujours goûter un
peu pratiqué dans une poche serait quand
même un peu déformant un peu gros un peu
et bêtement mais l'idée c'est que vous
pourriez mettre en gros une tablette
dans votre poche vous prenez tacle
glissé bon mise à part a été seul à être
un petit peu plus gros eh bien vous
pourriez mettre carrément une tablette
dans votre poche
et ça pour moi c'est vraiment cool pour
l'instant aérienne sur là dessus ça a
été montré à partir d'une publication
sur weibo il ya un écran qui était pris
en photo et y aurait une pub directement
dessus où on voit la lueur de l'écran se
permet de voir comment ça si tu
commences à sa brique bon c'est vraiment
très très clairement juste une île et je
suis pas sûr que ce produit sorte en
tout cas ça montre qu'à une vraie
réflexion sur le pillage de quelle
manière on lé pli quels sont les usages
comment ça va être à l'avenir et qu'est
ce qu'on va pouvoir faire avec ses
smartphones là en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que l'idée d'une écran pliable
du smartphone ou pliable c'est soit
d'augmenter soit de réduire et après un
autrement qui me fait un peu peur c'est
le fait d'avoir une marque lorsque vous
utilisez un smartphone avec un écran
pliable et vous le sentez quand même un
peu saoul doit donc là vous auriez une
pelure de ce côté-là n'auriez une autre
de l'autre on sentirait quand même je
suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment hyper
hyper bon vous dois vraiment voir en
terme de finition après
industrialisation ce que ça donne c'est
pour ça que pour l'instant je me sens
quand même un peu dubitatif sur cette
idée là maintenant est-ce qu'on aurait
un galaxy folle deuxième du nom toujours
plus optimisée en enlevant cette espèce
de grande encore sur le quota par
ailleurs que je trouve pas complètement
dingue
non vraiment l'améliorer pourquoi pas
augmenter l'écran notification pourquoi
pas nous faire ré à l'écran ça pourrait
être cool pour tout savoir une seule
chose à faire vous
abonnez vous activer la cloche les
petits clics de tous les côtés comme ça
vous serez tous et je vous en parlerai
très clairement le 11 février
je serai à san francisco avec samsung je
verrai tout ce qui va se passer je vais
tout vous raconter vous emmener dans les
coulisses du vous emmener dans
l'histoire vous montrer tout au tout de
a à z
on va tout raconter ça c'est vachement
cool et j'ai vraiment hâte déjà voir ce
qui se passait du côté des a priori
galaxy s demain ça pourrait être le
nouveau nom de ses produits voir ce
qu'il se passait du côté du pillage losc
est passé du côté de l'écosystème a
priori pour y avoir aussi des nouveaux
bugs je pense que ça me saoule mais une
belle histoire à nous raconter
et je pense qu'en 2020 on a vraiment se
régale avec plein de nouveaux produits
super intéressant super passionnant vous
avez bien évidemment à dreux joindre à
vous me dire maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire qu'est ce
que vous attendez vous de samsun en 2020
qu'est ce que vous attendez que
quelqu'un vous voudriez voir arriver
comme produit et qu'est ce que vous
pensez
tu pour arriver au niveau justement des
smartphones guyane vous invite à marquer
tout ça en bas vous l'écrivez en
commentaire moi ce que vous en pensez et
campagne on se retrouve dès demain pour
continuer à parler de teck fait les gros
bisous dans votre amour du locle est
calme et bien d'autres
[Musique]
mexes
m
[Musique]
vous
les